what do you think of when i say the word
design
you probably think of things like this
finely crafted objects that you can hold
in your hand or maybe logos and posters
and maps that visually explain things
classic icons of timeless design but i'm
not here to talk about that kind of
design
i want to talk about the kind that you
probably use every day and may not give
much thought to
designs that change all the time and
that live inside your pocket
i'm talking about the design of digital
experiences and specifically the design
of systems that are so big that their
scale can be hard to comprehend
consider the fact that google processes
over 1 billion search queries every day
that every minute over a hundred hours
of footage are uploaded to youtube
that's more in a single day than all
three major us networks broadcast in the
last five years combined
and facebook transmitting the photos
messages and stories of over 1.23
billion people that's almost half of the
internet population and a sixth of
humanity
these are some of the products that i've
helped design over the course of my
career and their scale is so massive
that they've produced unprecedented
design challenges
but what is really hard about designing
at scale is this
it's hard in part because it requires a
combination of two things
audacity and humility
audacity to believe that the thing that
you're making is something that the
entire world wants and needs and
humility to understand that as a
designer it's not about you or your
portfolio it's about the people that
you're designing for and how your work
just might help them live better lives
now unfortunately there's no school that
offers the course designing for humanity
101.
i and the other designers who work on
these kinds of products have had to kind
of invent it as we go along and we're
teaching ourselves the emerging best
practices
of designing at scale
and today i'd like to share some of the
things that we've learned over the years
now the first thing that you need to
know about designing at scale is that
the little things really matter
here's a really good example of how a
very tiny design element can make a big
impact
now the team at facebook that manages
the facebook like button
decided that it needed to be redesigned
the button had kind of gotten out of
sync with the evolution of our brand and
it need to be modernized now you might
think well it's a tiny little button it
probably is pretty straightforward easy
design assignment but it wasn't
turns out there were all kinds of
constraints for the design of this
button you had to work within specific
height and width parameters you had to
be careful to make it work in a bunch of
different languages and be careful about
using fancy gradients or borders because
it has to degrade gracefully in old web
browsers the truth is designing this
tiny little button was a huge pain in
the butt
now this is the new version of the
button and the designer who led this
project estimates that he spent over 280
hours redesigning this button over the
course of months
now why would we spend so much time on
something so small
it's because when you're designing at
scale there's no such thing as a small
detail
this innocent little button is seen on
average 22 billion times a day and on
over 7.5 million websites
it's one of the single most viewed
design elements ever created now that's
a lot of pressure for a little button
and the designer behind it but with
these kinds of products you need to get
even the tiny things right
now the next thing that you need to
understand is how to design with data
now when you're working on products like
this you have incredible amounts of
information about how people are using
your product that you can then use to
influence your design decisions but it's
not just as simple as following the
numbers let me give you an example so
that you can understand what i mean
facebook has had a tool for a long time
that allow people to report photos that
may be in violation of our community
standards things like spam and abuse
and there were a ton of photos reported
but as it turns out only a small
percentage were actually in violation of
those community standards most of them
were just your typical party photo now
to give you a specific hypothetical
example let's say my friend laura
hypothetically uploads a picture of me
from a drunken night of karaoke
this is purely hypothetical i can assure
you
incidentally
you know you know how some people are
kind of worried that their boss or
employee is going to discover
embarrassing photos of them on facebook
do you know how hard that is to avoid
when you actually work at facebook
so anyway there are lots of these photos
being erroneously reported as spam and
abuse and one of the engineers on the
team had a hunch he really thought there
was something else going on and he was
right because when he looked through a
bunch of the cases he found that most of
them were from people who were
requesting the takedown of a photo of
themself
now this was a scenario that the team
never even took into account before so
they added a new feature that allowed
people to message their friend to ask
them to take the photo down but it
didn't work
only 20 of people sent the message to
their friend so the team went back at it
they consulted with experts in conflict
resolution they even studied the
universal principles of polite language
which i didn't even actually knew
existed until this research happened and
they found something really interesting
they had to go beyond just helping
people ask their friend to take the
photo down they had to help people
express to their friend how the photo
made them feel
here's how the experience works today so
i find this hypothetical photo of myself
and it's not spam it's not abuse but i
really wish it weren't on the site
so i report it and i say
i'm in this photo and i don't like it
and then we dig deeper why don't you
like this photo of yourself
and i select it's embarrassing
and then i'm encouraged to message my
friend but here's the critical
difference i'm provided specific
suggested language that helps me
communicate to laura how the photo makes
me feel
now the team found that this relatively
small change had a huge impact
before only 20 of people were sending
the message and now sixty percent were
and survey showed that people on both
sides of the conversation felt better as
a result that same survey showed that
ninety percent of your friends want to
know if they've done something to upset
you
i don't know who the other 10 are but
maybe that's where our unfriend feature
can come in handy
so as you can see these decisions are
highly nuanced of course we use a lot of
data to inform our decisions but we also
rely very heavily on iteration research
testing intuition human empathy it's
both art and science
now sometimes the designers who work on
these products are called data driven
which is a term that totally drives us
bonkers the fact is it would be
irresponsible of us not to rigorously
test our designs when so many people are
counting on us to get it right but
data analytics will never be a
substitute for design intuition
data can help you make a good design
great but it will never make a bad
design good
the next thing that you need to
understand as a principle is that when
you introduce change you need to do it
extraordinarily carefully now i often
have joke that i spend almost as much
time designing the introduction of
change as i do the change itself and i'm
sure that we can all relate to that when
something that we use a lot changes and
then we have to adjust
the fact is people can become very
efficient at using bad design
and so even if the change is good for
them in the long run it's still
incredibly frustrating when it happens
and this is particularly true with
user-generated content platforms because
people can rightfully claim a sense of
ownership it is after all their content
now years ago when i was working at
youtube we were looking for ways to
encourage more people to rate videos and
it was interesting because when we
looked into the data we found that
almost everyone was exclusively using
the highest five star rating a handful
of people were using the lowest one star
and virtually no one was using two three
or four stars so we decided to simplify
into
an up-down kind of voting binary model
it's going to be much easier for people
to engage with but
people were very attached to the
five-star rating system video creators
really loved their ratings millions and
millions of people were accustomed to
the old design so in order to help
people prepare themselves for change and
acclimate to the new design more quickly
we actually published the data graph
sharing with the community the rationale
for what we were going to do
and it even engaged the larger industry
in a conversation which resulted in my
favorite techcrunch headline of all time
youtube comes to a five-star realization
its ratings are useless
now it's impossible to completely avoid
change aversion when you're making
changes to products that so many people
use even though we tried to do all the
right things we still received our
customary flood of video protests and
angry emails and even a package that had
to be scanned by security
but we have to remember people care
intensely about this stuff and it's
because these products this work really
really matters to them
now
we know that we have to be careful about
paying attention to the details we have
to be cognizant about how we use data in
our design process and we have to
introduce change very very carefully now
these things are all really useful
they're good best practices for
designing at scale but they don't mean
anything if you don't understand
something much more fundamental
you have to understand who you are
designing for
now when you set a goal to design for
the entire human race and you start to
engage in that goal in earnest
at some point you run into the walls of
the bubble that you're living in
now in san francisco we get a little
miffed when we hit a dead cell zone
because we can't use our phones to
navigate to the new hipster coffee shop
but what if you had to drive four hours
to charge your phone because you had no
reliable source of electricity
what if you had no access to public
libraries
what if your country had no free press
what would these products start to mean
to you
this is what google youtube and facebook
look like to most of the world and it's
what they'll look like to most of the
next five billion people to come online
designing for low-end cell phones is not
glamorous design work but if you want to
design for the whole world you have to
design for where people are and not
where you are
so how do we keep this big big picture
in mind we try to travel outside of our
bubble to see hear and understand the
people we're designing for we use our
products in non-english languages to
make sure that they work just as well
and we try to use one of these phones
from time to time to keep in touch with
their reality
so
what does it mean to design at a global
scale
it means difficult and sometimes
exasperating work to try to improve and
evolve products
finding the audacity and the humility to
do right by them can be pretty
exhausting and the humility part that's
a little tough on the design ego
because these products are always
changing
everything that i've designed in my
career is pretty much gone
and everything that i will design will
fade away
but here's what remains
the never-ending thrill
of being a part of something that is so
big you can hardly get your head around
it
and the promise that it just might
change the world
thank you